Bonjour à tous. Ca fait des mois qu'on
en parle et le grand jour est arrivé.
Apple a annoncé non pas la sortie de un
iPhone, de deux iPhone mais bien de trois
iPhone pour marquer le coup à
l'occasion des 10 ans de l'iPhone du
tout premier iphone qui avait été
présenté en 2007 par Steve Jobs
la présentation a eu lieu dans le
nouveau Steve Jobs Theater directement
aux Etats-Unis et là franchement je
dois vous avouer qu'on n'est pas resté
sur notre faim. Alors deux premiers
iPhone qui sont en réalité la suite
logique de ce qu'est l'iPhone 7 et
l'iPhone 7 Plus, à savoir l'iPhone 8
et l'iPhone 8 Plus. Et un nouveau venu
dont on attendait effectivement
l'arrivée depuis quelques temps c'est
l'iPhone X. Ca s'écrit avec une
grande croix, on ne prononce pas l'iPhone
X mais bien l'iPhone 10. L'iPhone des
10 ans, l'iphone anniversaire. Alors
autant les deux premiers modèles iPhone 8
et l'iPhone 8 Plus sont la réelle
évolution de l'iPhone 7 et l'iPhone 7 Plus.
Autant l'iPhone X est vraiment,
selon Apple, ce que doit être le
téléphone du futur. Une vraie avancée
avec toutes les meilleures technologies
que vont avoir les smartphones dans les
années à venir.
Alors ce qu'on va faire dans cette
vidéo c'est qu'on va présenter ses
trois téléphones. On va les comparer.
On va regarder un peu la différence entre ces
trois modèles. Et à la fin voir lequel
est intéressant, s'il y en a un qui l'est.
Oui. Non. Quoi ? Comment ? Et voir la nouvelle gamme de prix pour les iPhone.
Que ce soit l'iPhone 8, 8
Plus ou l'iPhone X, ils ont tous
les trois soit 64 Go soit 256 Go. Les
rumeurs faisaient état d'un potentiel
512 Go mais ce n'est pas le cas. En
réalité, en terme de dimensions,
l'iPhone X se positionne exactement
entre l'iPhone 8 et l'iPhone 8 Plus.
Par contre, en termes d'écrans,
l'iPhone 8 un écran de 4,7 pouces
l'iPhone 8 Plus : 5,5 pouces et l'iPhone
X : 5,8 pouces. Il est plus petit en
dimensions que l'iPhone 8 Plus mais il a un
plus grand écran parce qu'il
occupe la quasi totalité du
smartphone. Et justement parlons des
écrans. Que ce soit l'iPhone 8 ou l'iPhone 8 Plus, ils ont tous les deux un
écran Retina HD Display. L'iPhone X
par contre c'est tout autre chose.
Autant les deux premiers sont des
écrans LCD, les écrans LCD qui équipaient
depuis longtemps la gamme des iPhone.
L'iPhone X propose vraiment tout autre chose.
C'est un écran OLED. Un écran
Super Retina HD Display bort à bord en
2436x1125 avec une résolution
de 458 ppi.
Les écrans OLED ont des contrastes plus saisissants,
des couleurs plus belles et a priori ce nouvel écran
de l'iPhone X irait encore plus loin
avec des couleurs beaucoup plus claires,
beaucoup plus de brillance. Vraiment
quelque chose d'extrêmement surprenant
qui serait a priori au dessus de ce
que l'on peut trouver sur le marché.
Je pense notamment au LG V30 que
j'ai essayé il n'y a pas longtemps ainsi que le
Galaxy Note 8 qui ont des écrans OLED qui sont d'une excellente qualité. Mais
à priori, selon Apple,
l'iPhone X serait encore au dessus.
Ils sont tous les trois équipés de la
puce A11 Bionic à six coeurs.
L'appareil photo de l'iPhone 8 a un capteur de 12 mégapixels avec une
ouverture 1.8. L'iPhone 8 Plus a par
contre deux capteurs de 12 mégapixels
chacun : un grand angle et un
téléobjectif. Le grand-angle à
l'ouverture 1.8 et le téléobjectif
2.8. L'iPhone X a lui aussi un double
capteur 12 mégapixels qui par contre
est à la verticale. Une ouverture pour
le grand angle de 1.8 et le téléobjectif
a une ouverture de 2.4. Cela
permettra d'avoir plus de lumière par
rapport aux deux autres modèles.
L'iPhone 8 a un zoom digital X5. L'iPhone
8 Plus a un zoom digital et un zoom
optique X10 et c'est la même chose
pour l'iPhone X. Que ce soit l'iPhone 8 Plus ou
l'iPhone X, ils ont tous les deux le
Portrait Mode que l'on connaissait déjà
sur l'iPhone 7 Plus mais il y a un
tout nouveau mode qui vient
d'apparaître c'est le Mode Lighting. Il est
pour le moment en version beta mais il vous
permettra de pouvoir modifier la
lumière de vos prises de vue
comme si vous étiez dans un studio
professionnel. Ou de pouvoir carrément
détourer tout le personnage, d'avoir un
fond noir et de le faire ressortir.
Cela permettrait d'avoir un rendu très intéressant. Notez que ces deux modes on les
retrouve sur la caméra de selfie de l'iPhone X. Une caméra de selfie
en 7 mégapixels. Puisque l'on parle des caméras de selfie
on va y rester
puisque la caméra de selfie de l'iPhone 8 et
de l'iPhone 8 Plus ont toutes les deux une
caméra de selfie en 7 mégapixels
Full HD avec une ouverture de 2.2.
C'est exactement la même chose pour
l'iPhone X avec une ouverture de 2.2 pour la caméra de selfie. Tous ces smartphones
se rechargent par induction.
Le système de
déverrouillage change entre les iPhone
8 et l'iPhone X. Sur l'iPhone 8 et l'iPhone
8 Plus vous avez le Touch ID.
Sur l'iPhone X c'est tout autre chose avec
le Face ID. Qu'est-ce que le Face ID ? C'est tout simplement votre caméra
de selfie qui va reconnaître votre
visage. Qui l'aura au préalable scanné
qui connaîtra les moindres détails de
votre anatomie, de
votre visage et ça vous permettra
de le déverrouiller juste
en posant son regard sur son iPhone.
Comment ça marche ? Vous avez un
capteur infrarouge, un capteur de proximité ...
C'est extrêmement précis. Il a une
chance sur un million de se tromper
contre une chance sur cinquante mille
avec le Touch ID.
C'est vraiment sécurisé. Ca
fonctionne même dans le noir grâce
à la caméra infrarouge. Que vous
portiez des lunettes, que vous ayez un
chapeau, nouvelle coupe de cheveux,
...
Votre téléphone sera en mesure de vous
reconnaître et de se déverrouiller.
Pour les verrouiller c'est très simple, il
suffira de le regarder, il s'activera et
ensuite avec votre doigt vous glisserez
vers le haut et vous arriverez sur vos
applications.
Il y a une vraie sécurisation
avec le Face ID. Si quelqu'un veut scanner une photo de vous ça ne marchera pas
D'ailleurs Apple utilise
cette caméra de 7 mégapixels sur
l'iPhone X pour
animer les Animojis.
Ce sont des Emojis que vous pouvez
utiliser dans vos messages. Puisque la
caméra reconnaît exactement la forme
de votre visage et l'a scannée. L'a
numérisée en quelque sorte, elle est
capable de reconnaître les mouvements
de votre visage et de les appliquer aux Animojis. Le résultat est très rigolo.
Cela permet d'envoyer des messages personnalisés en faisant
parler un cochon, un coq, une poule ... c'est vraiment très
très marrant. Tous ces smartphones
sont livrés, bien évidemment, avec le
fameux smartphone, un adaptateurs
Lightning - USB, Lightning - port jack ,vous
avez aussi votre prise pour
brancher le port USB et le recharger, ainsi
qu'une documentation.
Ces trois modèles sont en verre
que ce soit sur la face avant ou sur la
face arrière. Apple a
annoncé que le verre serait le plus
résistant jamais utilisé sur les
iPhone. Donc a priori pas de risque de
casse mais à mon avis ça vaut quand même le
coup d'acheter petite protection. L'iPhone 8 et l'iPhone 8 Plus
sont disponibles en couleur or, en argent et en gris. Quant à l'iPhone X il est disponible
en argent et en gris. Les trois modèles
ont de nouveaux haut-parleurs stéréo 25%
plus puissants que ceux du modèle
précédent. Grâce à nouvelle puce
A11 on peut exploiter la
réalité augmentée. Ca vous
permettra bien évidemment de jouer à des
jeux vidéo dans votre pièce comme si
vous y étiez au travers de votre écran.
Ca vous permettra d'être dans des situations
super drôles avec différents jeux. Ca
vous permettra également lorsque vous
serez par exemple à un match de foot, de
rugby, ... d'avoir des
informations précises sur les joueurs, de
pouvoir les reconnaître ... ce sera
quelque chose de très sympa. Ils nous ont également présenté une troisième
démonstration : vous aurez la carte du
ciel et vous pourrez visualiser
les constellations ... ça peut être
vraiment sympa à faire
notamment les belles nuits d'été.
La réalité augmenté va se développer énormément vous
allez avoir plein de nouvelles
applications.
Aujourd'hui c'est encore un gadget mais dans les années à venir
ça va devenir vraiment quelque chose de non pas indispensable mais
incontournable.
Les trois smartphones sont équipés
d'un bluetooth 5.0. Vous pourrez
précommander l'iPhone 8 et l'iPhone 8 Plus
à partir du 15 septembre et ils seront
disponibles à partir du 22 septembre au
tarif de 699$ pour l'iPhone 8 et de 799$
pour l'iPhone 8 Plus. Pour l'instant on
n'a pas les tarifs pour la France mais on
imagine qu'ils seront un petit peu plus
cher. On peut imaginer des prix à 750,
800€ pour l'iPhone 8 et
probablement 850, 900€ pour l'iPhone 8Plus.
C'est encore hypothétique
en règle générale les prix en euros
sont plus élevés que les prix en
dollars annoncés par Apple.
L'iPhone 10 sera disponible en
précommande le 27 octobre et
disponible à partir du 3 novembre au
tarif de 999$.
On imagine que en euro dépassera largement les 1000€.
Probablement 1100€ voire 1200€.
L'arrivée de ces 3 nouveaux
smartphones vont forcément avoir une
répercussion sur les prix
de l'ensemble des iPhone. l'iPhone SE passe à 349$, l'iPhone 6S à 449$,
l'iphone 7 à 549$
et je vous ai déjà donné tous les autres
détails pour l'iPhone 8, 8 Plus et
l'iPhone X. Maintenant la question
à se poser est : quel iPhone choisir ?
Vous avez le choix entre
tout une large gamme d'iPhone. Si vous voulez commencer à
rentrer dans la gamme des iPhone,
l'iPhone SE est très bien mais si
vous voulez tout de suite monter en gamme avec des nouvelles
fonctionnalités et vous amuser, passez
directement sur l'iPhone 8 voir l'iPhone 8 Plus.
Je ne saurais que vous
recommander l'iPhone 8 Plus pour les
nouveaux modes de prise de photo parce
que ce sont des choses qui vont devenir de
plus en plus sympa. Vous pourrez
faire des photos de meilleure qualité.
Surtout que l'on fait
beaucoup de photos aujourd'hui,
c'est indispensable d'avoir le
meilleur appareil photo.
Je suis déçu par la caméra de selfie des iPhone 8 et 8 Plus.
Elle n'est pas suffisamment performante.
7 mégapixels c'est insuffisant.
Si vous êtes youtubeur, si vous êtes
créateur de contenu vous avez besoin de
vous filmer, de pouvoir vous regarder et
vous filmer en même temps, avec cet
appareil là, la qualité ne va pas être
extraordinaire.
Vous pourrez filmer en Full HD,
pas de 4K mais comme le capteur
n'est pas génial vous risquerez d'avoir
un contenu de qualité assez moyenne.
A voir que ça donnera sur le
capteur de selfie de l'iPhone X.
Même si il a un un capteur de 7
mégapixels, on va avoir de nouvelles
performances. Le capteur de 7
mégapixels de l'iPhone X
risque d'être un petit peu mieux pour
pouvoir faire des selfies. Vous pouvez
notamment utiliser le mode portrait et
le mode lighting directement sur votre
caméra de selfie. Il se peut
que cette caméra soit mieux
pour faire des vidéos sur Youtube.
Ca reste quand même à voir et
à tester. Si vous deviez faire
un choix entre l'iPhone 8, l'iPhone 8 Plus
ou l'iPhone X : lequel choisir ?
Le premier paramètre c'est
forcément l'argent.
Si je ne devais en choisir qu'un seul je
prendrais bien évidemment l'iphone
X. Pourquoi ? Pour l'écran : un
écran OLED Super Retina HD
c'est un écran d'une
extrême grande qualité. Un grand écran
borderless, c'est la tendance, c'est super,
c'est magnifique. Pour avoir vu des écrans OLED je peux vous assurer que
vous ne serez pas déçu par rapport à
un écran LCD. C'est vraiment autre chose.
Selon moi le Face ID, aujourd'hui,
c'est un gadget. Ce n'est pas
nécessairement très  intéressant
par rapport au Touch ID. La vraie
différence, le vrai choix, doit se faire
entre l'iPhone 8 Plus et
l'iPhoneX et se fera uniquement sur la
qualité de l'écran.
Dites-moi ce que vous en pensez ? Est-ce que vous avez été convaincus par ces
différents smartphones ? Qu'est ce que
vous pensez de l'iPhone 8, de  l'iPhone 8 Plus,
de l'iPhone X ?
Est ce que vous envisagez d'en acheter un ?
Si oui lequel ?
Que pensez-vous du prix ?
Vous surprend-il ? Le trouvez-vous bien ?
Que pensez-vous du prix de l'iPhone 8 ?
On pouvait s'attendre à plus cher, ça peut
rester cohérent. Dites-moi tout ce que
vous en pensez en commentaire et
j'ai hâte de pouvoir en discuter avec vous.
Je vous invite à vous abonner ma chaîne parce qu'il y aura toujours plus de contenu pour vous
aider à réussir sur Youtube et
également à connaître tous les
produits influence et les produits
intéressants pour votre réussite sur
Youtube et aussi dans votre vie digitale.
Quant à moi je remercie beaucoup
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo et je vous
dis à très bientôt et d'ici là
portez vous bien. Salut !